no me toda la información económica en
france 24 y por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches bienvenida
iniciamos hablando del gobierno de
venezuela que amenaza con quedarse con
los bienes del diario 'el nacional' o la
valentina buenas noches
todo comenzó en agosto de 2015 el
periódico el nacional replicó una
información del diario español abc que
decía que el número 2 del chavismo
diosdado cabello estaba siendo
investigado en eeuu por presuntos nexos
con el narcotráfico el dirigente lo
demandó por difamación seis años después
el oficialista tribunal supremo de
justicia condenó al que hoy en día es el
único diario de oposición que todavía
sobrevive en este país aunque sólo en la
versión digital lo condenó a pagar 13
millones de dólares en indemnización por
daños y perjuicios pero sus directivos
dicen que no cuentan con ese dinero y
varias asociaciones de prensa se han
solidarizado por lo que consideran una
estrategia para ejecutar una
expropiación encubierta el mismo
diosdado cabello respondió este jueves
con la siguiente advertencia
si ellos se la dan de duro y no quieren
pagar que el edificio sede del nacional
si así lo consideran los tribunales es
entregado a este que está aquí
inmediatamente yo firmaré para que ese
edificio se convierta en la sede de la
universidad de la comunicación es
bastante contundente esta advertencia de
venezuela vamos a chile porque los
sindicatos amenazan con una nueva ronda
de protestas contra el gobierno por el
retiro de las pensiones
valentina del senado de ese país aprobó
este jueves el tercer retiro anticipado
de los ahorros de los ciudadanos en su
fondo privado de pensiones ahora lo
devuelve a la cámara de diputados para
el trámite final y después va a sanción
presidencial pero el gobierno de
sebastián piñera ya amenazó con
rechazarlo y enviarlo al tribunal
constitucional el miércoles hubo
protestas cacerolazos y barricadas en
contra de esta decisión gubernamental y
hoy varios sindicatos industriales entre
ellos el de la minera más grande que es
codelco amenazaron hasta con ir a vuelta
ellos dicen que ese retiro es la única
solución para enfrentar la realidad
económica de la pandera
lo curioso valentina del trámite
legislativo es que siete de los 31 votos
a favor de la iniciativa vienen del
oficialismo y hay voces que hablan de
una crisis en la coalición de gobierno
pues dejamos a américa latina y nos
vamos a eeuu porque se dispararon los
precios de la vivienda y valentina se ha
sido uno de los efectos de la pandemia
mire la gente ha comprado más vivienda
usada y ahora hay una gran competencia
por las pocas que quedan disponibles
esto disparó los precios en 17 2% hasta
un nivel histórico de 329 mil dólares en
promedio en marzo de 2021 comparado con
un año antes
hace un año una casa duraba casi un mes
en venta y ahora apenas 18 días y
cualquiera que se ponga a la venta
recibe múltiples ofertas por encima de
su precio este resultado está impulsado
en gran parte por las tasas de hipoteca
históricamente bajas hoy están a menos
del 3% anual valentina daniela y nos
vamos a turquía porque están abriendo
una investigación una nueva
investigación por estafa con cripto
monedas
recordarán que hace apenas un día
informábamos que en españa comenzaron a
investigar una supuesta estafa piramidal
con cripto monedas dear vistas 2.0 que
podría tener más de 30 mil víctimas hoy
ocurre lo mismo pero en turquía en donde
justamente el uso de kriptón edas para
pagos y bien de bienes y servicios
estará prohibido desde el próximo 30 de
abril las autoridades se apostaron
frente a este edificio en estambul
buscando el rastro de fire para ti o ser
quien es el fundador de la popular bolsa
de intercambio de cripto monedas de c's
quien huyó al extranjero después de
captar al menos dos mil millones de
dólares el sitio web de la empresa
publicó un mensaje que dice que estas
acusaciones que hablan de 392.000
afectados son infundadas
daniela vamos ahora con los indicadores
económicos hubo rumores este jueves de
que el presidente joe biden quiere
duplicar el impuesto a los grandes
ingresos y eso golpeó a wall street por
el contrario las acciones europeas se
movieron hacia máximos históricos tras
sólidos informes de ganancias
empresariales
y en américa latina' tercera caída
consecutiva para la bolsa de sao paulo y
cerramos con la cifra del día 6 millones
de dólares esta cifra la entregará la
unión europea a perú en financiación de
estudios y asistencia técnica para
promover sistemas de transporte urbano
sostenible en 29 ciudades
daniela gracias por toda esta
información a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros hoy más
aquí en france 24
[Música]